il est le président des centristes en
union avec cette liste de la droite et
du centre
il est président de région de france et
président de la plus belle région de
france présidant la normandie hervé
morin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ja mesdames et messieurs on va tout
d'abord dire bienvenue à françoise aviez
bellamy
on ne dira pas bienvenue à gérard
larcher puisque il est sur ses terres
mais on est heureux que tu sois là ce
soir gérard et on souhaite aussi la
bienvenue à laurent wauquiez
comme je lui ai dit lors d'un meeting à
lyon il est président d'une petite
région ça doit lui faire du bien des
prisons d'une bête présent dans une
grande région ce soir
manche et à françoise et mon cher
françois xavier quelques mots seulement
parce que c'est toi qu'on est venu
entendre et gérard et et laurent
simplement pour te dire que on a vécu
une catastrophe nationale
avec l' incendie notre dame ce qui fait
que tu n'as pas pu faire ton premier
meeting à nîmes comme prévu et ce
premier meeting national et à caen en
normandie chez joël bruneau te dire que
tu as au moins cette chance là c'est que
tu es sur la terre des conquérants
tu es la terre des conquérants dont je
te rappelle que cette terre a donné un
roi à l'angleterre au moment du bric
site
je te rappelle que c'est la terre qui a
donné ses institutions au royaume uni et
son droit et je te rappelle enfin que
cette terre a conquis l'ensemble du
bassin méditerranéen et que lorsque tu
vas en sicile lorsque tu leva dans le
sud de l'italie tu vois des hommes et
des femmes qui ont les yeux aussi bleus
que toi c'est parce que en fait ils sont
descendants des normands alors peut-être
qu'au bout du compte tu es un candidat
issu de la normandie
en plus de ça comme je le disais tout à
l'heure tu dois avoir quelque part une
descendance normande parce que mon grand
père a été maire pendant trente ans
d'une commune du pays d'auge avec un
principal opposant politique
un dénommé bellamy donc ça aurait pu
être un élément qui aurait été at-on
passif mais bien et mesdames et
messieurs ce que je voudrais vous dire
simplement c'est que je le lui ai dit a
lyon je vous le redis puisque nous
sommes en normandie que vous n'avez pas
tous été à lyon je vous repère pour tous
ceux qui ont été absents eh bien on a la
chance d'avoir un candidat formidable
mesdames et messieurs on a la chance
d'avoir un candidat qui affiche une
réelle authenticité qui est un discours
neuf qui est un discours qui fait appel
à l'intelligence
un discours qui fait appel à la
réflexion et qui cherche à porter des
valeurs et un message et c'est pour nous
le plus bel atout nous faisons à la fois
appel renouveau de la vie politique à
travers un visage nouveau mais pas
simplement dans une espèce de marketing
qui a tenté à la mode depuis deux ans
mais parce que nous avons un homme qui
est capable de porter un vrai message
politique et qui est construit et avec
une intelligence rare et celle ci
mesdames et messieurs c'est une chance
immense pour porter le message que nous
voulons porter donc françoise aviez
continue à le faire
et mesdames et messieurs je voudrais
simplement vous dire deux choses
pourquoi nous avons décidé j'ai décidé
de participer à cette campagne
électorale parce que mesdames et
messieurs à travers cette campagne des
européennes
il s'agit de la première pierre de
l'édifice qui doit nous permettre de
construire une alternance vous voyez
bien ce qu'il est en train de se passer
en vérité emmanuel macron est sur un
schéma d'un cynisme absolument
extraordinaire qui consiste à vouloir
enfermer la france dans une équation
aussi binaire que celle ci si ça n'est
pas moi c'est le chaos
le chaos nous l'avons eu a écrit gilet
jaune on le remercie mais en clair c'est
entre le front national est en marche
que les choses se jouent et bien moi je
ne peux pas me résoudre mesdames et
messieurs que nous ne puissions pas
rapidement incarner une réelle
alternative au pays et les seuls
capables d'incarner cette alternative
demain et bien c'est le rassemblement
politique que nous incarnons aujourd'hui
et c'est la première cause qui doit nous
amener à nous battre pour ces élections
européennes c'est celle d'être en
capacité de construire cette alternative
dont la france a tant besoin
si déçu par les deux ans de la
présidence mâcon
la deuxième chose que je dis je le dis
devant le parterre très nombreux de
parlementaires présents deux
départements d'élus qui sont ici de
sénateurs deux conseillers
départementaux et régionaux
si qu'il y avait quand même quelque
chose de baroque dans cette histoire qui
aurait consisté que cette élection
européenne ne nous concernait pas et
qu'elle nous concerne et qu'en revanche
les élections municipales et les
élections départementales et régionales
elle nous concerne on ne peut pas
mesdames et messieurs est dans la même
majorité dans les villes même si ces
villes ont toujours des équations qui
sont des équations plus large
eden dans la même majorité dans les
départements est dans la même majorité
au sein des régions est considéré que
pour les élections européennes chacun
fait ce qu'il veut et que cela ne nous
concerne pas si on est ensemble on est
ensemble pour bâtir cette alternative et
c'est pas une équation est une équation
à géométrie variable
ça c'est ce que je voulais vous dire sur
l'aspect politique
et puis je voudrais simplement m'arrêter
moi qui suis profondément européen sur
l' espèce de mystification dans laquelle
en marche c'est de nous conduire sur ces
élections européennes en reprenant un
discours national comme si l'europe
c'était simplement l'état nation à la
française est en nous exprimant à peu
près les mêmes thèmes que ce que nous
pourrions trouver sur le champ de la
politique nationale alors qu'il s'agit
d'une équation bien entendu totalement
différente lorsqu'il s'agit de
construire une politique européenne
la première est là où mme joëlle a
parfaitement raison c'est que mesdames
et messieurs c'est trop facile d'imputer
à l'europe tous les défauts que nous
connaissons où toutes les faiblesses que
nous avons aujourd'hui si la france va
mal mesdames et messieurs c'est pas à
cause de l'europe c'est à cause de nous
si mesdames et messieurs notre système
éducatif et défaillance ça n'est pas à
cause de l'europe ces tacots
de nous si notre système judiciaire est
un des systèmes judiciaires les plus 10
fonctionnant philippe bas en sait
quelque chose
c'est pas la faute de l'europe c'est à
cause de nous et si mesdames et
messieurs nous sommes le pays qui au
monde dans le monde occidental à les
prélèvements obligatoires les plus
élevés
c'est pas à cause de l'europe c'est à
cause de nous et la plus précisément ces
tags grâce à emmanuel macron puisque
grâce à emmanuel macron nous avons battu
les records de françois hollande qui
nous amène à être aujourd'hui le pays le
plus imposé du monde occidental et donc
mesdames et messieurs il faut arrêter de
considérer que les décisions de l'europe
nous ont amenés dans la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes si autant de pays
européens sont aujourd'hui en situation
de plein emploi
ça n'est pas probablement parce que
l'europe leur aurait fait défaut comme
parfois nous savons trop facilement le
dire est par ailleurs mesdames et
messieurs arrêtez d'accabler l'europe
quand il s'agit de normes et de
décisions qui ne sont pas prises par une
espèce de structures ou d'institutions
qui serait tissu nulle part ces
institutions c'est d'abord et avant tout
un conseil des ministres dans lequel il
y a un représentant de la france
et à chaque fois qu'une décision est
prise et qu'elle est mauvaise elle est
prise avec l'accord de la france
contrairement à ce qu'on veut bien nous
raconter matin midi et soir
et donc il faut arrêter de se construire
des boucs émissaires trop facile quand
un pays depuis des années connaît une
crise aussi profonde et puis de l'autre
je voudrais vous dire que mesdames et
messieurs on entend sur cette campagne
européenne de la bouche de notre
candidate d'un oiseau candidate en
marche
pardon mais c'est parce que j'étais
parti dans l'histoire dans marche jeu
je l'évoquais ainsi je prends trois
sujets simplement le premier mesdames et
messieurs c'est la mystification qui
consiste à considérer que nous pourrions
bâtir un bouclier social européen et un
smic européen qui pourrait être contre
cette idée personne sauf que mesdames et
messieurs quand emmanuel macron propose
une idée n est partagée par personne en
europe et que pour bâtir un smic
européen faudrait-il que les 27 soit sur
cette manie des haies dames et messieurs
le smic de la bulgarie à 250 à 300 euros
le smic de la roumanie à 400 à 450 euros
ou le smic de l'espagne à 800 ou 900
euros tout le monde rêverait qu'ils
soient français il soit à 12 100 euros
sauf que mesdames et messieurs il ya
beaucoup de pays dans lesquels on
considère que d'abord et avant tout
c'est la question de la france et du
redressement de sa propre compétitivité
de la réduction des dépenses publiques
de la baisse des prélèvements
obligatoires de l'amélioration du
système de formation qui permettra à la
france de retrouver la croissance et le
plein emploi et puis deuxièmement
mesdames et messieurs s'il fallait qu'il
y ait un smic européen on n'imagine pas
un seul instant que ce soit un smic
européen à la baisse on n'imagine pas
qu'on puisse proposer aux français
d'aller vers un smic plus faible en
sachant à quel point il est tellement
difficile aujourd'hui d'arriver à vivre
avec un salaire minimum et bien la
réalité mesdames et messieurs de
lorsqu'on propose une telle idée c'est
qu'on dit à un certain nombre de pays
européens
vous êtes incapable de rester dans
l'espace européen puisque votre économie
ne supporterait pas le choc une
augmentation considérable des niveaux de
salaire quand votre performance
économique et bien entendu largement
inférieure à celle des pays les plus
développés donc quand on évoque cette
idée comme l'a fait madame oiseaux il ya
quinze jours
soit on est totalement incompétent ce
que je ne pourrais pas croire de
l'ancienne directrice de l'ena qui va
désormais devoir supporter la
suppression de l'ena soit tout
simplement on a décidé de mentir aux
français parce que c'est bien cela dont
il s'agit oui on ne supporte pas la
concurrence déloyale oui cet espace
européen c'est a grandi trop vite mais
considéré que la solution c'est d'amener
demain matin les roumains les espagnols
les bulgares ont les polonais aux mêmes
smic que nous c'est bien entendu mentir
parce que l'économie de ces pays serait
incapable de supporter 7 ce choc là il
ya donc une mauvaise foi absolument
totale
mesdames et messieurs je crois un
deuxième sujet c'est celui des
travailleurs détachés emmanuel macron
avait fait durant la campagne
présidentielle
un engagement modifier les règles sur
les travailleurs détachés en vérité sur
la modification des règles des
travailleurs détachés
la chose qui a été changée c'est
véronique le passage de 24 à 18 mois le
temps où un travailleur détachées
peut-être à l'étranger
sauf que mesdames et messieurs le temps
moyen d'un travailleur détacher ses
quatre mois et dont on voit la
pertinence de cette histoire et pire
encore mesdames et messieurs il faut que
vous le sachiez vous qui êtes dans une
région qui a créé des règne sur ces
appels d'offres pour empêcher cette
concurrence déloyale et parce que moi
j'estime qu'il n'y a aucune raison qui
est des hommes et les femmes qui
travaillent 70 heures par semaine et qui
dorment dans une camionnette parce
qu'ils seraient polonais bulgare oruma
quand on fixe des règles naturellement
protectrice et logiquement protectrice
pour nos propres nos propres
compatriotes et bien mesdames et
messieurs au bout du compte
brillant public a fait mieux que ça il a
envoyé l'ensemble des appels d'offres
présentées par toutes les régions et les
collectivités qui avait créé des règles
pour empêcher qu'il puisse y avoir sur
les chantiers publics des travailleurs
détachés
donc en clair on a eu d'un côté à
présent à public a expliqué aux français
qu'il fallait changer les règles et qui
de l'autre à envoyer
devant le conseil d'état l'ensemble des
marchés des collectivités sur la
question des travailleurs détachés alors
qu'elle avait décidé de construire un
nouveau modèle pour en effet permettent
tout simplement à l'économie régionale
ou nationale de pouvoir travailler avec
l'argent public issu de nos décisions
budgétaires et je vous donne enfin un
troisième exemple lié à mon ancienne
histoire qui est celle de ministre de la
défense
mesdames et messieurs elle est belle
cette idée armés d'armes et européennes
sauf que mesdames et messieurs je suis
au regret de vous dire qu'elle ne
correspond à rien elle ne correspond à
rien pour trois raisons la première
c'est que malheureusement les européens
ont démissionné sur les questions de
défense et de sécurité qu'ils ont décidé
de confier leur défense leur sécurité à
d'autres en l'occurrence aux américains
dans le cadre d'une alliance qui
s'appelle l'alliance atlantique
on peut le regretter on peut s'en
désoler mais la vérité elle est là c'est
que la plupart des européens consacrent
plus d'argent à leur défense et qui
n'ont jamais voulu mettre en avant la
défense européenne préférant se réfugier
derrière l'alliance atlantique
la deuxième raison mesdames et messieurs
c'est qu' il existe des briques de cette
défense européenne et ses briques elles
n'ont jamais été utilisés par les
européens
certes on fait des opérations comme
celle de la protection des bateaux au
large de la somalie
mais les européens ont toute une série
d'instruments comme ceux qu'on appelle
les groupements tactiques qui sont
préparés prêts à être envoyés par les
européens sauf que les européens n'ont
jamais trouvé les conditions réunies
pour pouvoir le faire
et souvenez-vous quand nous sommes
intervenus en afrique du temps de
françois hollande pour lutter contre al
qaïda et l'ensemble des mouvements
islamistes
eh bien on s'est retrouvé tout seul et
enfin mesdames et messieurs ce dont nous
avons besoin pour la construction
européenne ce n'est pas d'une armée
européenne dont personne en vérité ne
veut
et ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
d'abord et avant tout d'eux bâtir ce
qu'on appelle les bric d'une
souveraineté en matière de défense et de
sécurité et notamment de faire en sorte
qu'une et des briques technologiques et
industrielles parce que ce que emmanuel
macron ne vous dit pas c'est que lorsque
nous vendons aux saoudiens au qatari aux
égyptiens lorsque nous vendons ce qui
est notre fleuron nos fleurons
technologiques nous sommes obligés de
demander l'accord des américains parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de briques
technologiques sur lesquels il faut
l'accord des états unis pour pouvoir
vendre et exporter nos matériels et bien
c'est là on a besoin de bâtir notre
souveraineté
c'est bâtir notre souveraineté sur ce
qui représentera demain la base d'une
technologie de défense nous permettant
ensuite de pouvoir nous déployer sur
l'échelon de la souveraineté
et puis enfin mesdames et messieurs sur
la question de l'armée européenne je
vous dis une chose simple je suis comme
je voulais dit profondément européen
mais s'il ya bien une seule chose que je
ne veux pas confié c'est ma sécurité
ultime à d'autre qu'à ma propre nation
et qu'il y a
et qu'il y à mesdames et messieurs un
schéma simple quand il s'agit de sa
souveraineté et de sa sécurité ultime
sol la nation et l'espace dans lequel
doit se discuter
une telle décision et qu'elle
n'appartient ni aux bataves ni aux
italiens ni aux espagnols ni encore aux
allemands et que je veux rester maîtres
et souverain quand il s'agit de ma
propre sécurité et donc le cher ami le
chef de l'état nous a fait un discours
extrêmement formidable et puissant sur
la question européenne et dans le même
temps il n'a pas eu le moindre écho au
sein de l'europe
pas le moindre élément du discours de la
sorbonne ou divise secours d'athènes n'a
fait l'objet de la moindre mise en
oeuvre à l'échelle européenne
et d'ailleurs il a obtenu comme seul
remerciement une fin de non-recevoir
d'angela merkel lorsqu'il a présenté ses
propositions et donc ce dont nous avons
besoin de bâtir ce que nous avons besoin
de bâtir mesdames et messieurs c'est
d'une force politique au sein de la
droite et du centre européen au
parlement européen sont capables de
bâtir un projet simple oui nous sommes
européens
non nous ne sommes pas béat et oui nous
devons bâtir un modèle dans lequel on
accepte de remettre en cause un schéma
qui n'est plus partagée par une majorité
de nos compatriotes en le bâtissant sur
une espèce d'alchimie intelligente entre
la nécessité de l'europe sur des schémas
et des sujets fondamentaux et la
nécessité de la nation et de l'état sur
des sujets là aussi qui relève de notre
propre légitimité et c'est ce schéma là
que nous dépendons et françoise aviez
bellamy et c'est ce seul schéma que
souhaitent les européens
il n'y en a pas d'autre ce schéma là je
vous invite à partager durant le
prochain mois
je vous remercie